from the post-millennial Maine superior
court orders Trump back on the ballot
pending scotus ruling so this is good
news Trump has been allowed allowed back
on the ballot in Maine thanks to the
state's superior court on Wednesday the
court issued a stay of Maine Secretary
of State Shanah Bellow's move to prevent
Trump from being a candidate arguing
that no decision should be made until
the Supreme Court of the US has handed
down its ruling according to Fox News in
addition to staying Bell's ruling the
court denied Trump's motion to
supplement the record and stay
proceedings so so the matter has
remanded to Bellow for further
proceedings is necessary in light of the
US Supreme Court's forthcoming decision
in Trump V Anderson the case against the
former president in Colorado that also
seeks to keep him off the ballot there I
think the big risk right now and the
reason why they're doing it right
now Trump may win all of
these but how much do you want to bet
come super Tuesday many states
California for instance take him off the
ballot and they make the argument this
is not the general election no one's
interfering in the general election but
Trump is off the ballot and Nikki Haley
wins yeah if that happened there might
be the first time we ever see a right-in
candidate win some uh uh uh I'm I got to
look more into this but I'm hearing that
like Virginia's trying to get away with
the uh they're trying to pass a bill
that makes it so you can't write in a
name I got to look into that one I got
to verify that one yeah well I think
they're trying to print the ballots
before The Supreme Court ruling comes
down because I think they wanted to say
oh we got can't do it now we can't go
back now and that's going to be the big
it's too late it's uh 90 days and so uh
you know look we we we made the ballots
going to fortify the crap out of the
election already we already know they're
doing it they wrote the NBC news article
saying that they're they're they're
planning to uh stop Trump again they are
absolutely trying to do everything they
can to fix the election there's this is
not going to be a free and fair election
they will do anything at all to to fix
the election to defend democracy they're
so they're and everybody that believes
them you are so dumb yeah it's like a
red flag when someone says that it's so
bad it is it really is and it's it's
it's painful to watch you know people
that you you're friends with that like
you you used to respect or whatever and
they're just like yeah manine you know
he's after our democracy and it's like
oh so you're going to take him you
should take them off the uh off the the
ballot yeah that's how you save democ
okay all right the the one I get is when
they're like Trump's a fascist and I'm
like bro this whole country is fascist
let's just get that out of the way man
we got the Federal Reserve in our back
like well that's that's it's worse than
the Federal Reserve is worse than
fascism it's something different like at
least with fascism they're standing in
front of you telling you they're do it
they're doing it you know what I mean
the Federal Reserve is basically like
behind the scenes no one pays attention
and it's Shadow regulating controlling
how you can live your life yeah it's
it's beyond corporate yeah fascism is
too specific right the reference to we
need new words for these things I think
technocratic but claiming that the
Federal Reserve is techn ratic doesn't
quite make sense when they go digital if
they go digital when they go digital
that Central Bank digital currency I
hope that they I could shut down but
that's about as technocratic as I've
ever seen something like that would be
like oh this is a technocracy trying to
take hold but we need to keep maintain
our
Republic yeah that's the thing it's
really funny because in the uh in the
the statements that come from um what
was I reading I was reading a statement
from some Republican they said our
Republic and when you read a statement
from a Democrat they say our democracy
all the time and and you know I was
thinking about I did a segment today and
I kind of I don't think I was articulate
enough in what I was trying to explain
but I was thinking about a better way to
explain it's really simple a republic is
when a guy from your state argues to
neighboring states and to the federal
government your view your your Region's
view on how uh your like how your laws
should be how the greater laws should
affect your state or your city or
whatever and that the federal government
has limited control or access to what
happens in your state a democracy would
be everyone in New York voting on what
Wyoming gets to do with their water so
in a direct democracy the system they
want Chicago will vote the people of
Wyoming must leave in a republic the
people of Wyoming laugh you know
their guns and say try it that was
basically the you know democracy versus
Liberty as stated by Benjamin Franklin
so what we're seeing right now with
Democrats is they do this they try to uh
they make the argument that
at the national level they should be
able to vote away the rights of the
states and the Republicans and I mean
that in the literal sense not the
Republican Party make the argument the
states decide what happens within the
states I see moving forward it is
obvious the Democrats want to do away
with the Republican with with a
republican
system it's funny because just because
calling that party Republican doesn't
mean that they value the Republic and
calling that party the Democratic Party
doesn't mean that they have Democratic
Values at all like they could be those
parties could be called the red party
and the blue party but it it it you're
you're right about the names but it is
funny how the Democratic party wants
democracy and the Republican party wants
Republican yeah it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy they they like
to play these cult games these people
that have so much money trillionaires
and stuff that they they're so to the
occult I wonder if they're doing this
out of Joy they're like yeah let's use
the Democratic party for direct
democracy and then control with mob
mentality direct democracy would be the
most brutal and awful system especially
with social media with Google being able
to twist the human mind and get 600
million people to click a button one day
like the amount of mob Force we got we
got to do this we should do this really
soon the the the idea I had for uh de
Dem Democratic what's for dinner the
idea being there's a list of ingredients
everyone chooses their favorite
ingredients and then democracy is
everyone gets to vote on what's for
dinner so you vote like I like you know
spinach and I like uh mint and someone
says I like red peppers and someone says
I like bacon and then whatever the
Democracy rule Democratic rule is we say
okay we're going to throw all all of
like the the the things that won get
thrown in the pot and it's going to be
the most disgusting meal you've ever had
yeah CU someone say like you know I like
cotton candy yeah so it's like okay
first you decide what's for dinner
lasagna Pizza sandwiches everyone then
votes the winner is sandwiches the next
thing that comes up is what's your
favorite you know uh uh vegetable and so
you'll end up eating like raw broccoli
sandwiches with chocolate sauce well
that's everyone voted they like
chocolate sauce everyone voted they like
broccoli we made dinner using what
everyone voted on the the point here is
I'm not going to go to a chef and vote
on what he should use to bake to to to
make me a nice steak I'm G to say I
elect representative Chef Gordon Ramsey
to oversee the production of my stake I
believe he's the right guy for the job
you take care of it direct democracy
would be like the the kitchen announcing
all the ingredients and then asking you
to vote on how it should be done and
then a bunch of people have no idea the
example I gave before is that if you
asked people to vote on making cookies I
guarantee you or I'd be willing to bet
the majority of people would vote no
salt in my
cookies because they don't understand
and they assume salt you put sugar in
cookies you don't put salt in cookies
but you do put salt in you put a little
bit and so the average person not
knowing any of this would be like no no
salt and cookies are you nuts and they'd
vote against it and then you'd get awful
cookies
that's
democracy and there's this a constant
scop too going to get people to like to
think that democracy is the be all end
all there's no guarantee that democracy
is going to produce positive results the
only guarantee is that you're going to
have a majority of people that have you
know that say they want this and that's
what it's going to be but that doesn't
mean that the majority of people know
what the B the a good outcome is to to
achieve whatever end they're looking for
yeah evidence would show that a direct
democracy is very bad for the the
minority it's bad for the majority
direct democracy does not mean the
majority rules because you you direct
democracy does not mean we vote one time
and we're done what kind of system do
you want here's a big list of all the
things we're going to do we vote on it
and we're done Utopia the majority live
in the in the system they wanted no no
my point about making dinner we're going
to make grilled cheeses what do we put
on it you're going to get chocolate
sauce asparagus mushroom grilled cheese
with with vegan cheese it's going to be
the weirdest thing ever because in
democracy you're always voting on
something else coming up and not
everyone agrees not the majority does
not agree on everything there is no the
majority there is on many issues a
majority here on an issue of majority
here you might say hey we found through
a direct vote through a survey 51% of
people out of 100 like like pizza we
then found 51% of people out of 100 like
chocolate ice cream however of that 51%
of people who like chocolate ice cream
half of them like pizza and half of them
like sandwiches you get my point not
everybody who likes Pizza likes the same
dessert so if you're voting on policy
like how should we deal with carbon
emissions how should we deal with fossil
fuel you will find different groups of
people forming the majority in every
different area which means when it comes
to direct democracy your system will be
ruled by two 2% of the population the
microscopic 2% that wins the majority on
a bunch of different issues and thus for
dinner you will have a sub sandwich with
green peppers raw broccoli chocolate
syrup mint and I don't know Anis sprayed
all Anis extract sprayed all over it
just some weird amalgam of various
groups that vote on the things they want
that's democracy what's the alternative
a republic where you say I am going to
elect a representative to actually go
out and solve the problem so instead of
voting on the ingredients that I like I
tell Ian here's the stuff I'm really
into I like green peppers I like
broccoli I like chocolate syrup and then
Ian goes totally get it I'm going to go
to the kitchen and talk to the chef he
talks to the chef and says we're not
going to do anything as stupid as put
broccoli and chocolate syrup on a
sandwich but my guy for dessert likes
chocolate for dinner he likes green
peppers and the chef says how about we
do a Philly cheese steak that sounds
pretty good right and we'll do a side of
broccoli salad cuz he likes that that's
republic versus direct democracy which
is nonsense and and ridiculous yeah you
have the idea in a republic is that you
have better men in quotes you know
that's what they used to call them
better men that you would send to go
make the decisions for you because they
understand the things that they're
deciding on they understand implications
and opportunity costs and things like
that but still we we we have the problem
of snake wheel salesman in in a in a in
a de with Democrat democratically
elected representatives money getting
into politics really screwed things up
in a in a just maybe almost
unconscionable way the amount of money
that a corporation that a pack can give
to one guy like the santis what 200 how
much did he make 99 million or something
right there you're refuting your own
argument how so because you're saying
that money matters like all the money
that descent like money getting into
politics is a bad thing look at all the
money that Dan santis got and Dan santis
is losing yeah but if he if he had to do
it on his own then he' be speaking his
mind he'd be more like into his campaign
but that doesn't mean that he'd be
winning no I I disagree I think I don't
know Donald Trump spent so little his
first campaign run that's my point like
Barack Obama like Hillary Clinton spent
like a billion dollars and she lost one
of the biggest mistakes people make is
saying I could do it if only I had money
yeah it's not true cuz I think the money
makes people become subservient to the
donors abely doesn't well give me an
example of someone that hasn't become
subservient to their donor class that
hasn't be well there's there there is
well Marco Rubio made a really great
point when someone said you're taking
money from the gun lobby so they're you
know so they're making you agree with
them he's like no no no no because of my
views on gun rights the gun lobby makes
donations to me it's the other way
around there are people who will be
holding to their donors because someone
comes up to them and says look we can
provide your pack $50 million but we we
we're we don't want you going hard on
insert issue and they might say yes that
does happen but typically what happens
is the lobbyists will say who's the best
candidate to get through a bill that's
going to do this thing for us oh well
candidate a they go to him and say we
hear that you're very interested in
these issues is that something that
works for you yes it is great going to
support you that's typically how it goes
the amount of money that like individual
like uh politicians can take from a a uh
a donor is not really Grand or something
it's not really a lot of money that's
why they have packs you know you can
give money to packs and they can and
they can do stuff that the the the
politician would want to do but they're
not technically working together I just
want to stress this point for everybody
listening here's some Financial advice
it's not literal it's success advice
call it that money is not your problem
it will never be your problem the people
who say things like I've heard this
every step of the way throughout my
career if only I had the money then I
could do it I'm like that's not true
right so it's like you know somebody we
we'll use journalism in example I wish I
could travel around the world and cover
journalism and do these stories and it's
like okay well you need money to buy a
plane ticket you don't have the money
you can't do that right that's not where
the job starts the job starts with you
going to your local areas and building
what you can with what you can and Aver
every day you're adding a grain of sand
to the heat I didn't start doing this
show and traveling and I didn't start
out doing this by traveling the world I
bought a $20 bus ticket to New York and
film things on my phone okay but you
need a phone fine Fair Point you need a
certain degree of resources to do things
but it's not cost prohibitive to work a
job that pays 15 bucks an hour save up
to get a basic smartphone that can film
and then start filming things around
your area where you live not only that
someone wants to get started doing this
kind of work right now holy crap is it
easy you're 18 years old you get a job
at Starbucks you make 15 bucks an hour
save every cent sleep on a floor
sacrifice buy a smartphone take a bus to
the southern border and film every day
and post on X for free guess what give
it 3 four five months you're going to
have 10 20,000 followers give it a year
you got 100,000 followers all of a
sudden you're getting calls from every
major Network saying can you come on the
show and talk about what you're seeing
yes I can a year goes by and then you're
having convers ation with people where
you're like I'm an expert on the
southern border I've been literally down
there for a year sleeping outside
filming this stuff going on and it costs
you almost nothing I will say Brianna
you actually walked away from I imagine
a lucrative contract in your corporate
career where were you working before you
went independent so my I I worked in
sports first thing I was going to jump
on that next but I worked in sports and
I went over to Fox and then I worked in
the media the corporate media World from
there on because I was at Fox I was
working as a weekend booking producer
for Marita baroma and Wall Street Jal at
large and then I literally when I got to
New York City which was very expensive
uh got back to New York City they were
like vaccine or or you know you're out
uh so ultimately yeah but you know
what's so interesting too is I actually
started my career by starting a digital
Sports uh Radio Show online and
literally with no Resources with like
with like the bare minimum cheapest
microphone and my laptop like was able
to somehow get like all these views cuz
I ended up getting going viral in a
couple of interviews and then I got my
job at ml
and so ultimately you really don't need
that much the difference is his drive
though there were so people in my
college who were like making up excuses
they couldn't do this they couldn't do
that but drive is really kind of the
difference in all of that and most
people don't have it sadly especially
the generation coming up they're they're
all full of excuses but none of them
want to actually do the hard work we're
seeing that now I noticed that too like
I pumped out a thousand videos in 2006
and S and like 99% of them sucked but
those few that got traction got the
eyeballs of people that then took me to
the next stage of my life yeah building
out social media thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net